es un paso adelante en el apoyo a
Ucrania a los 14 tanques de leopardos a
6 procedentes de la reserva del ejército
alemán llegarán a Ucrania Berlín su
fabricante además ha dado luz verde a
sus socios europeos para que reexporten
los vehículos militares sin embargo
desde el gobierno intentaron mantener un
tono conciliador y prometieron no
escalar la guerra
debemos dejar siempre muy claro que
estamos haciendo lo necesario y lo
posible para apoyar a Ucrania pero que
al mismo tiempo estamos evitando la
escalada en una guerra entre Rusia y la
otan y siempre vigilaremos el
cumplimiento de este principio
y es que una posible guerra entre la
otan y Rusia presentaría un escenario
muy desalentador motivo de las reservas
de Alemania para mandar los tanques pero
la presión de sus socios y las llamadas
de ayuda de Ucrania hicieron que el país
europeo al final es debiera
los principales tanques de combate
alemanes ampliación adicional del apoyo
a la defensa y a las misiones
entrenamiento además de luz verde para
que los socios suministren armas
similares Acabo de enterarme de estas
decisiones importantes y oportunas en
una llamada con Olaf shows sinceramente
agradecido con el canciller y todos
nuestros amigos en Alemania a pesar de
que es un tema que divide a los miembros
de la Unión Europea la mayoría apuestan
por mandar armas y tanques a Ucrania
diversos países entre ellos Francia o
Reino Unido o la misma Polonia implicada
directamente han celebrado la decisión
Gracias
la decisión de enviar tanques leo para
Ucrania es un gran paso para detener a
Rusia juntos somos fuertes se espera que
los tanques estén operativos y los
militares entrenados para finales de
marzo a tiempo para la reactivación de
la ofensiva que se espera para Primavera